Вітаю студія Вітаю глядачі телеканалу ну
власне сьогодні сталася безпрецедентна
подія коли мене як народний депутат
України як голову під комітету членкиню
профільного комітету А так само
тимчасової спеціальної комісії якого
очолює Яна Зінкевич з питань захисту
прав ветеранів просто не пустили на
форум який організований був
міністерством ветеранів для мене це є
просто обурлива ситуація коли ми в
демократичній країні парламентського
президентській Республіці де уряд
підзвітний парламенту і в той час я
півтори години простояла під дверима і з
незрозумілих причин мене туди не
впустили і ви знаєте я хочу сказати
Величезне дякую пан у спікеру Руслану
стефанчуку який з трибуни форуму заявив
що
учасникам форуму ветеранам ветеранським
організаціям міжнародним представникам
потрібно співпрацювати з-під комітетом з
питань реабілітації ветеранів які я
очолюю але при цьому я стояла під
дверима і не мала змоги ні потиснути
руку нашим достойним захисникам і
захисницям ні познайомитися з
представниками міжнародної спільноти для
того щоб в подальшому напрацьовувати ті
потрібні і важливі проекти які стануть
основою і фундаментом нашої роботи з
ветеранами Україна буде країною молодих
ветеранів і нам потрібно спільно
докладати багатьох зусиль Натомість ми
бачимо цілковиту політизацію процесів
погане ставлення до представників
опозиції І власне Я не розумію чому так
трапляється коли народні депутати не
мають змоги брати участь в обговоренні і
формуванні ветеранської політики
правда дуже дивна ситуація Враховуючи те
що пан стефанчук там говорив Ну а як вам
аргументовували чи пояснювали чому вас
не пускають на захід
Ну спочатку Мені пояснили що мене немає
в списках Хоча я працювала в цьому
напрямку і мене завірили в тому що я є в
списках
заходи безпеки і просто були зачинені
двері і Мені відповіли що зараз
завершиться офіційна частина Тому я
вимушена була стояти на вулиці і
очікувати коли з форуму вийде пан
міністр оборони
Олексій резніков а пані Верещук пан
стефанчук вони вийшли двері зачинилися і
ми власне продовжували стояти на вулиці
за зачиненими дверима це обурлива
ситуація я вважаю що в Україні це
нагадує часи Януковича А коли була
повністю подавлена свобода слова і
можливість демократично вільно
висловлювати свої думки свою позицію і
об'єднувати зусилля задля Перемоги пані
Ірина А скажіть будь ласка офіційна
частина ми так зрозуміли закінчилася А
сам форум чи триває чи чи вже ні я
просто питаю для того щоб запитати тоді
далі а чи була у вас можливість з паном
Русланом стефанчиком поспілкуватися і
запитати як так вийшло
на жаль у мене не було такої можливості
тому що поважні гості досить швидко
покинули форум він власне продовжує
зараз відбуватися з відповідними
панельними дискусіями і обговореннями
але на жаль у мене немає можливості
потрапити на цей форум тобто фактично і
далі вас не пускають навіть попри там же
заходи безпеки спростились вочевидь
попри те що офіційні особи залишили там
офіційну частину чи як
ви знаєте я простояла спочатку пів
години на одному в ході а потім я
простоїла хвилин 40 А можливо більше на
центральному вході я локацію не буду А
поширювати з заходів безпеки і після
того як минуло півтори години Я просто
покинула це місце розуміючи що в
принципі далі немає сенсу стояти під
дверима і очікувати що когось впустять а
когось не випустять це при тому що в
залі було присутнє близько 1500
учасників і на жаль у мене не було змоги
поспілкуватися з ветеранами в той же час
хочу сказати що я досить багато часу
приділяю комунікації з нашими
захисниками і захисницями я кожного
місяця відвідую Донбас відвідую зону
бойових дій спілкуюся з нашими
військовослужбовцями на різні теми які
стосуються корупції при проходженні ВЛК
при проходженні мсеку при отриманні
учасника бойових дій І власне я як
чоловікиня профільного комітету докладаю
багато зусиль які фракція європейська
Солідарність для того щоб напрацювати
той алгоритм і той порядок який
максимально спростить отримання учасника
бойових дій а в подальшому відповідних
соціальних пільг і гарантій Але тим не
менше маємо зараз такого бурливу
ситуацію я вважаю що це просто Вибачте
хамське відношення до представників
парламенту